good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
tuesday that feels like a monday but
it's not because it's actually a tuesday
which is so great for us
so great for us so sensational we
absolutely love to see it
how was your long weekend well thank you
so much for asking thank you guys for
giving me the space
that i needed i needed this monday off
because like i said at a wedding on
sunday night and
i was actually thinking at the wedding
how i want to talk about this on the
toast because you guys know i
hate weddings like and i'll honestly
rsvp no to most weddings
but this might have been without the
exception of like family weddings
because of course that's like always the
best night
i think it was my favorite wedding i'd
ever been to do you think it's because
it was the first in so long and everyone
was so excited to be there and
that helped the the vibes were just so
excited
that definitely helped because it was
the first wedding like back but i always
say like a wedding is not so much about
like
the the decor and the ambiance as it is
about the couple this was just like a
great couple who like
really loved each other been together
forever their friends are best friends
with each other so it was just like
great energy
and the wedding itself was also like
stunning and elegant which didn't hurt
so it was just like my favorite wedding
i've been to in a while i always find
myself like so bored at weddings like
counting down the clock like to when
it's not rude to leave what's so funny
weddings are so fun it's like
one it's an excuse to get so dressed up
which we never ever
get that dressed up to like the music's
always amazing like live music
all your friends there's just so much
fun yeah like i guess like it should be
something i enjoy
maybe it's just because i'm such a
narcissist like i just can't
they can only spend a certain amount of
time like it being about someone else
like maybe that's
actually if i was a therapist like that
is what i might suggest to myself i
don't think that's what it is i do think
that all of the activities are not
claudia friendly no it's like so much
standing and like
you'll get your food until like four
hours until you're actually there it's
like we have to get all dressed up yeah
i have to listen to a singer who's not
me
he actually um they had amazing music
too that definitely contributed to the
positive vibes
and it was just like a wonderful evening
and i just i don't know if my opinion on
weddings has changed completely
post pandemic you mean post-pandemic but
i really am now even more kind of
cemented in my belief like i'm very
particular about where i rsvp
you know okay okay it was a great time
it was a great weekend
stunning weather i couldn't have been
luckier oh and that's the other thing it
was like kind of chilly which i was
living for you know yeah yeah and it
really just kind of i didn't sweat it
all and that's always with the weddings
inside the sweating and this heels like
it just gets to a point where i'm like i
have had enough of being tortured by
this couple
happy for you i have to leave also i've
noticed that post pandemic my heel
tolerance is back at zero like i can't
wear heels for more than
30 minutes like all of the blisters and
the
muscles that i had built up in my feet
wearing heels over the years like when i
put on a pair of heels after the year
and a half like
my feet can't handle it that's why i'm
always wearing flats also
our our first sponsor of the day is the
cup the brand that i wore to the wedding
and i got literally so many compliments
and i was so proud of myself i usually
make it to the dance floor for 30
minutes before i'm that girl who's like
walking around in the flip-flops oh
i hate that i hate being that guy i hate
the look of like your dress and the
flip-flops and like
i see it's tough it's tough i made it
not only to the car
i made it all the way up to my home we
drove back it was like an hour and a
half drive
literally i made it to my front door
they were the most comfortable shoes i'd
ever worn oh my god that's today's
sponsor
just wait till you find out i think i
think you should share the sponsor now
because i need to know
i think i know but you need to know it's
shoedazzle okay first of all they sent
over
their looks they have some of the most
sickening shoes i was obsessed with the
ones that i got i wore them to the
wedding
so comfortable never got more
compliments on anything in my entire
life wow
they're so affordable like my dress i
spent so much money on nobody looked at
me twice
my shoes shoe dazzle everyone was
quaking
i got three pairs of shoedazzle shoes a
few weeks ago their
looks for this season are so goddamn
cute so please
so on tread so on trend so comfortable
so affordable
tell them where they can get their shoe
dazzles okay take a quick style survey
for personalized outfit
recommendations on shoedazzle.com and
you can shop from hundreds of styles
that are curated just for you you can
choose to check out as a guest or become
a vip member
which honestly given how many sickening
styles there are i would recommend
becoming a vip member just because
why have to choose you know just get all
the shoes um and the perks of becoming a
vip member are you can save up to 30
all day every day and you get early and
exclusive access to new styles
collections collaborations vip executive
sales and promotions
they do sickening like collabs with
different people but like the the stuff
that they have up now like seriously
perfect for summer so affordable and
it's just like
i was i was shook not gonna lie like
when i got these pair of shoes i'm like
these are perfect for the wedding and
they're so affordable so go to
shoedazzle.com
toast if you want to get started become
a vip member or
shop um
as a guest but i think vip is weird the
way to go shoedazzle.com
toast sorry i didn't mean to just like
push the sponsor in there but it was so
appropriate
i missed the days when like we would
talk about the sponsor and then just
like
share the sponsors it's just so organic
we're so naturally
like stunningly authentic so since you
were already talking about it i think
that like everyone else would have been
rdh if you didn't share
i got so many comments like where are
the shoes from yeah shoot [ __ ]
shoot us become a vip member i had such
a productive
great weekend like so much fun was had
so much content was consumed
tv read so much like i have so much to
share with you that i watch and i read
are you ready for it
100 friday night i watch in the heights
yes i know i need to see it
so good i think you'll really like it i
never saw the play but zack had and he
loved the play so he was so excited to
watch it the music is so good the
dancing everything
the only thing is it was really long and
so
i don't know how you might be out you
might be out now you'll have to like
break it up
that's like the one thing that you could
have said like because like i mean i'm
so down
it was longer than anything i've ever
watched in my life that's really
annoying i think it was as long as the
titanic i swear
no okay then i finished the book woman
before wallace i would not recommend it
then i read another book the good sister
by sally hepworth who also wrote
mother-in-law which claudia loved
mother-in-law i did
i liked it and i loved the good sister
and i would recommend it to
everyone if you liked verity i think
you're really gonna like the good sister
wow our lights just like went out over
here oh our sign
it's okay the neon time it's fine or
were they never on oh yeah we were
removed
wow we are living in the future we are
xenon the 21st century
light okay so i finished two books
i started why women kill oh do you love
it loving it
loving it so much and like i'm watching
before bed i miss having a show that i
like so much
there's not that much on the streaming
service one season and then two seasons
of the new episode uh two episodes of
the new season it's more than enough for
me because i don't want to like be
watching tv all day
oh camera light and then i watch
housewife and the hustler
which we're going to talk about today as
a story because it's actual news what's
going on
with this story and i'm so beyond
shocked and i watch it as well
my perspective has changed now that i
actually understand what happened yes
and i'm so disgusted me too
disgusted yeah so i'm really looking
forward to talk about that we have
so much to talk about today yeah i mean
i don't really have
any like content recap because i was
just basically like you know being
social the whole weekend for me you were
putting out a lot of content and it's
like claude with no job only wakes up
when you're out of the city i'm making
what the hell am i going to take a
picture of me in my bed that's where i
am all the time
no i know but it's just like it's so
funny no i know i'm not like a
consistent poster on claude with no job
which is my personal instagram account
make sure to follow it
only once she's on vacation though only
when i look pretty like i'm not going to
torture everyone
i seriously like monday to friday i
i'm here and i work from and then i work
from home
all my photos on my instagram page are
from here like i can't
do anything i understand like this is
the struggle for us
i came alive you you come alive once i
hit that midtown tunnel or the holland
tunnel
claude with no job starts levitating
like she comes to life
yeah we love to see her we really do
she's churning out some premium content
yeah she works like she's so fabulous i
think i might do like a photo jump
that's like my new favorite trend
i love it on instagram because first of
all i'm not gonna post
10 times but you do have like 10
pictures and i feel like it's a really
cute thing to do
at the end of a long weekend you have
all these photos and you have to edit
every single one of them like with the
preset
you just the first just the first one
yeah so i actually really like this
trend i hope we keep doing it
no i like it a lot and i agree are you
good i'm so glad we're on the same
dump page yeah we've never talked about
it but i just love taking a photo
no taking dumps is like literally one of
my favorite activities i
could do it multiple times a day i'm
sure that you do i wish i would
um okay well are you ready to get into
everything is there so much to discuss
the chrissy teigen like we have we have
literally mountains to climb
mountains to climb and so i think we
should just jump right in the water's
warm i think we should dive off the deep
end
oh oh that's a thing you know i won't
respond
no from a quiet place oh i'm not gonna
watch it so that's fine
okay if you saw a quiet place then you
know this
wow if you were listening as a podcast i
did a hand gesture i can't um
you can't replicate it yeah okay without
further ado
to do where are you not here because
we're doing something really fun after
this that's just like
do would be way too chaotic oh yes i
think maybe
maybe you guys know because we've just
kind of been like you know so subtle
in our promotion but there are big
things coming this week
big things yes and we're we're shooting
something really fun today so yeah we're
excited so i
you probably know what it is yeah but
whatever we're just so subtle like
anyway it's not a secret and by tomorrow
like we'll be able to share but like
i just feel like before we take the
pictures and stuff like i just what if
the pictures are bad
well we're still going to do what if
they're not you no no but we're not
going to use the pictures you know
we still have like other pictures yeah
no i know i'm just saying i just hate
jinx and stuff it's not about youtube
project it's just about jinx you jackie
does hate like saying things
i hate talking about stuff before
they're there whereas like for me like
i'm
itching out of my clothes the second i
like find something out like we've been
designing but we've been working on this
project for
like literally this particular one for
like eight months and i've been wanting
to talk about it since the day we
started no i know
i think we could just share what it is
yeah we're dropping merch we are
dropping march this week that is
literally our favorite stuff that we've
ever dropped and we're going to take
some really cute pictures today
if you've been following us on social
we've been doing like a little you know
oh just me just like a little you know
you know a little
claudia loves the teaser i do i just
love to be the one to like you know drop
the news
yeah and i'm happy for you so that'll be
coming
in a few days so yeah so just stay tuned
for that also speaking of amazing things
patreon is popping off yeah yesterday we
posted a general q a where we answered
all of your guys's questions for as many
as we can get to about like
you know our show our lives the show the
future just like
random questions that you guys have for
us which was really fun and we posted a
vlog of getting snitch ready for a date
which everyone thought was so funny
it was so i loved it like i wasn't there
you filmed it i watched it it was like
the highlight of my day and didn't she
look
amazing well maybe that's why i was so
enjoyable to watch because like the last
vlog we did together like you were
getting me ready and i was like so
chaotic and i looked so fat and ugly and
like margo's just like oh i just got
this like
new you know little body suit let me
just put it on stunning model
oh let me just run some blush through my
cheeks stunning model let me just grab
my purple shoes from zara
stunning like it was just so easy and
she wore the first thing she picked out
like who does that it was a joy
a dream yeah i looked like the ugly
troll
okay now without further ado to do where
are you
not here because we're doing something
oh my gosh that's how that all started
yeah
thanks for bringing it back here are the
fast life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and as we already said today's episode
is brought to you by shoedazzle.com
shoedazzle.com toast check it out
do not sleep on shoe dazzle i've been
upping my shoe game and shoe dazzle has
come in the clutch and i just want to
say i'm very pro sleep like i think you
should sleep on most things
not true dazzle i agree okay first story
big news of the weekend chrissy teigen
drama continues to unfold she put out an
apology
blog post on medium yesterday where she
apologized for the past things that she
had tweeted and messaged
to young girls many years ago right we
haven't spoken about this we haven't
spoken about the drama
yet because like honestly i just like
don't care about her but it's become
like such a big story but like we should
talk about it
and for those who don't like know she
had tweets
they're still up and i think people have
known about them for a while but like
this kind of
um story gained a lot of momentum
recently
where she was just like saying some
really horrible things to
courtney stodden mostly also lindsay
lohan
at the time who were just like you know
young girls in the spotlight
saying like really um aggressively vile
things like not really
so much even as jokes just like
basically telling them
telling them to kill themselves um
some of them were disguised as jokes
like one about lindsay lohan every time
she sees
emma stone on a red carpet she puts
another slit in her wrist which is so
disgusting um she told courtney stodden
to like take a dirt nap go to sleep
forever
so people were really really upset by
this and you know as it goes
things started to happen the
cancellation of chrissy teigen brands
pulling out her cookware line it was
pulled out of target
she's been radio silent for a while yeah
for about a month and then yesterday she
wrote a blog post on medium
where she apologized for her actions
and her past tweets and that's you
thought would be the end of it but then
but before we dive into the end of it we
just talked about her post
yeah sure because um you know i actually
relate to this story i have tweeted
things that i deeply regret and i
actually think part of her
essay was really well said and i just
related to it a lot like she'll like be
in the middle of the night get like
a stabbing pain in her back remembering
something horrible she said like
i actually really related to that but i
think what i did not like about the
apology is
it felt at times like very lighthearted
like making jokes like it felt like my
own episode of my name is earl like
there's not the time for jokes chrissy
like this is actually serious like i
just felt like it teetered between being
genuine and then like almost like being
too lighthearted and like making a
mockery of it
yeah i can i can see that well then what
happened last night was michael costello
posted on his instagram he is a designer
if you don't know him he was on project
runway and now he has
a line at revolve and he claims that
chrissy teigen bullying him
left him suicidal so he shared a story
saying for the past seven years i've
lived with a deep
unhealed trauma he said that in 2014
teagan uh quote apparently formed her
own opinion of me based on a
photoshopped comment
floating around the internet which has
now been proven to be false by instagram
and since taken down
he said he attempted to explain the
mix-up which apparently made it seem as
if he'd used a racial slur
to tegan who claims who he claims told
me that my career was over and that all
doors would be shut from there on
so he shares dms where he's like chrissy
please call me like i need to explain
this is not this is by a disgruntled
employee like i never said that
when this like thing happened to michael
costellos in 2014 chrissy teigen
commented on his post
racist and it kind of blew up this like
little story that like
one of his employees was sending around
like a fake instagram comment of his so
chrissy teigen like blew it up and so he
reached out to her and was like wait
please let me explain like it's not what
it looks like
and she responded read what exactly what
she responded she responded racist
people like you deserve to suffer and
die you might as well be dead
your career is over just watch so he
goes on to claim that the fashion
industry colleagues and friends told him
that tegan and her stylist monitor
i'm sure you remember that name the
thief remember she was stealing from the
kardashians and then the kardashians
fired her
and chris sent out an email to everyone
and everyone in the hall in their circle
like fired monica rose except chrissy
teigen
so he said that they had allegedly gone
out of their way to threaten people and
brands that if they were in any shape
or form associated with me they would
not work with any of them
each time i have pleaded with chrissy
teigen or monica rose to see the whole
story before believing a false narrative
a former disgruntled employee cast upon
me
they don't give me the time of day he
said after that i didn't see the point
of living
there was no way i can ever escape from
being the target of the powerful elites
in hollywood
he said i am not okay i may never be
okay but today i am choosing to speak my
truth
so when you and i we were together when
we saw this
and we were actually saying because i
mean there's no way to prove that monica
rose
and chrissy teigen were blackballing him
like he says what i mean but i believe
him but i understand what you're about
to say so like
because he said like you know so many
opportunities that were supposed to come
this way never came he was pulled from
shoots last minute
there was just so many things that made
it seem like he was being blackballed
and he believes it to be from chrissy
teigen and monica rose
there's really no way to know that but i
do have to say
we were talking about michael costello
because like you know what this actually
really makes sense
this happened in 2014 and i remember
first hearing about michael costello
when beyonce popped up at the grammys
like unannounced in this sickening white
gown and it was by
like a no-name designer and it was
michael costello and
and he had been on project runway he had
been on project runway and it was like
the biggest deal ever and then i was
before that was the first time i heard
of him
and you would think someone like that
would become like the next christian
syrian 100
and now i'm like i hear michael costello
like i own a bunch of his things because
he does do size inclusive thank you
michael
um because they sell on revolve which is
cool but it's not where someone who
designed for beyonce at the grammys
would be
and so then we were like what year did
that beyonce grammy's outfit happen
2014 what year is he saying he was
blackballed 2014.
so honestly like the career trajectory
of michael costello like really does
track with this story
because he had so much momentum and then
like kind of like nothing
yeah and this story just really changed
the way i looked at the bigger story
because like what chrissy and monica did
to him
that's cancel culture yeah like saying
you'll never work again and then
continue going out of your way going out
of your way to make sure that that
happens and also
then to say you know that you might as
well be dead like
it takes it to such a disgusting level
and this is like a pattern clearly of
hers telling other people to kill
themselves what is that
what is that that's a really [ __ ]
like weird thing that's not like a joke
it's not like cute and quirky like
that's [ __ ] dark like you need help
and so i feel like this is a really
interesting
we love to talk about cancer culture
here and i feel like this is like a
really interesting crossroads
and now it feels like the cancer is
being canceled right so this is a really
interesting crossroads because
i feel like as a society even though it
doesn't always feel that way most
normal people are very against cancer
culture most normal people think if you
said something in 2014
and you are now you know living a
completely different life like we're not
going to hold you
like we don't think that you actually
think that anymore i think for the most
part people really feel that way and
they want to fight against cancer
culture
but there's something about chrissy
teigen that like people don't want
to apply that line of thinking to and
and i was trying to think of like why
that is most normal people feel that way
but that's still
not what happens when someone gets
cancer so right but so
i think that like why people don't want
to apply that line of thinking to
chrissy teigen is because like honestly
when i think of like the type of people
who perpetuate cancer culture
i like include chrissy tegan in that
like she's always on twitter like
with reporters and like all the people
on twitter like with the blue they call
them like blue check mark like
freaks like those are the people who
like dig up your past to like
try and prove a point and those are the
people that chrissy tegan like
knows and tweets with and hangs out with
so like i just kind of include her in
this group of people
who do perpetuate cancer culture and
that's why
i've always said like it's so stupid to
get involved and like start canceling
people because like i don't care who you
are like
it's coming for you and this is the
exact perfect example like chrissy
teigen
yeah like you have been parts of you
know
other people's cancellations and like of
course they came for you yeah it always
does
and honestly yours might be the worst
i've ever seen well i don't know because
i do feel like and it's the way that
michael histillo said it like she
is like that powerful hollywood elite
she is in that circle like those are her
friends
i don't think that they'll keep her down
long
yeah well so that's the thing like
hollywood protects its own like i do
think at the end of the day like she
will be fine
because the thing is with chrissy teigen
she's always just been a celebrity
period like she just never it always
helped that she had all these fans and
followers but she's a famous model and
she's john legend's wife like
she'll be famous forever you really
she's uncancelable really
but she did build this brand herself of
like her cookware and her cravings books
and people like on the end like
consumers are done with her but like
hollywood loves her
yeah but i think that's the difference
between like what you said most normal
people are against cancel culture
but then people still get canceled like
yeah i don't
it's confusing this one was it's a doozy
this one's a doozy and i think
that i after her apology post last night
i would have thought that that was going
to be you know like a new
so turning a new page for her and then
we'll see what happens from there but
this story just
this is the worst thing to come out
about her yet and it's after her apology
i agree
so i don't know where we go from here
like as a society yeah or for
for her where she goes from there yeah
and honestly this just like
and honestly justice for michael
costello he's a really talented designer
i completely agree and amongst the many
things i'm
like taking away from this like monica
rose is the biggest loser i've ever met
in my life
now she's like over two on public
scandal like yeah
first she was like what did happen with
her the kardashians she was charging
them for items she was getting for free
and like saying it was like something
all stylists do but like it's not yeah
and for years they didn't notice until
like one
chloe just said it's like check her
credit card one time um and she was
doing it to all the sisters
so they let her go and chris like chris
told
pretty much everyone and chrissy teigen
was the only one who stood by her and
now
this is the second thing i'm learning
about monica rose and i just want to go
on record she's going on my list of
losers yeah okay you ready for our next
story
it's some big podcasting news oh yes
spotify clinches a deal with alex cooper
for call her daddy podcast yanking it
away from bar stool
alex cooper and her sex positive podcast
caller daddy are leaving barstool sports
coming to spotify exclusively starting
next month under a multi-year
deal all existing and new episodes of
call her daddy will remain free and
starting july 21st will
be available only on spotify in addition
to bringing the podcast to spotify
exclusively the deal also covers all
future episodes and additional exclusive
new projects in development
with cooper um the important part the
multi-year agreement
between cooper and spotify is worth more
than 20 million dollars per the wall
street journal which first reported on
the talks last week
so we report on every time spotify like
picks up a podcast because it's super
interesting and i think the podcasting
world is just like constantly evolving
but this is even more interesting
because it's really like a part of a
developing story over the last year when
we were all
literally the entire world was invested
in the call her daddy drama
and you and i said and a lot of people
did not agree with us because they
i mean we didn't take sides but i always
said like if i was one of those girls i
would have done exactly what sofia did
and i would have ended up getting [ __ ]
because
i knew that everyone knew the show was
worth more than what barcelona was
offering them
and they thought everyone called sofia
greedy for wanting what like 500 000
salary when literally if they were just
like a normal podcast at a normal
network
they would be worth 20 million dollars
right so
now it's like and like if
imagine if they had shopped the show
like together as a team after barcelona
like they would have been so
i mean it's still huge and it's so
interesting but like i do think this is
like what sophia was trying to do with
superman
right and they were and they were
feeling
the only thing is their contract wasn't
up so it just wasn't their time
oh their contract wasn't no they had one
more year on it but they didn't want to
do
well at the time they didn't want to do
that one more year like being paid
so little when the show was worth
clearly when the show was worth millions
so i was really curious to see what
would happen because i feel like
everyone knew they had one more year
everything happened a year ago like
what's gonna happen
and they were like is is dave going to
give them that ip like are they going to
get the name
is she going to stay with barcelona is
she going to go elsewhere but i think
when you know there's 20 million dollars
on the table
even if she likes her time at barstool
you got to go to spotify
and she is still slightly partnered with
barstool they are doing her merch and
her newsletter
yeah so she kept them involved which is
nice yes they did you know
give her the platform at first yeah so
this is just really interesting spotify
they also we didn't report on this
because like we wouldn't but they also
scooped up armchair expert yes your
favorite yes i
am so excited to listen to armchair
expert on spotify
i just find dax shepard's so annoying
like i know people are obsessed with him
but like my god
like be more annoying at dario yeah the
only thing is i don't know how much he
got for that deal i haven't seen that
anywhere because like honestly nobody
cares like we all just want to know how
much alex cooper got like yeah and joe
she's more interesting we all know about
100 million right that's just so crazy
because like joe rogan was podcasting
for years and i call her daddy it's so
crazy we've been through so much with
them
it's two years old correct no it's three
years old oh
that's wait no two years i think it's
three years
time goes by oh it does go by okay they
had they did it since 2018. now it's 20
21.
that's three years okay so that's still
pretty long um no it's just like such
crazy news
yeah and i just love all this money
being invested in podcasting you just
absolutely love to see the medium just
growing you really
really do i'm such a fan of different
mediums you know i am a fan of different
mediums
i really like the long island medium but
i also like um
henry what's his name uh tyler tyler the
medium tyler henry
tyler henry also i feel like this story
um
sorry there's a male coming through what
is he saying
does the word oh sorry my throat is
tightening somebody died of
asphyxiation it's coming through and
he's saying
oh wow he's saying epstein didn't kill
himself
yeah it's jeffrey epstein i've been
i've been taking over the body of
jeffrey epstein claudia's been possessed
by jeffrey epstein
um i just want to say i just feel like
this story has been like an open case
for a year like kate
i feel like now case closed yes mystery
is solved of like what they were worth
and blah blah blah
and where they would go and who got the
ip
and then now i would say case closed and
sophia has her own show that does pretty
well and i'm sure she makes a lot of
money but like
yeah not 20 million i know and i'm sure
so many people are like
sophie i'm sure is like vomiting
vomiting but i think that it was clearly
a toxic work situation
for both of them that eventually was
going to end badly no matter what
happened
and it seems like each girl is doing
great on their own i listen to both
shows sometimes i think i like sofia
with an f
so much you know i'm always telling you
i'm laughing out loud i know sophia is
really funny i'm just on the side of
female friendship and i would have loved
to see this work out you know for the
for the female friendship i'm on the
side of comedic duos as well
we love to just support fellow comedic
duos
but i'm also on the side of just you
know everyone doing what's best for them
and their mental health
yeah 100 so i think this is like a happy
ending
to it's also just like such an
interesting case study like for
podcasting yeah but i also am glad to
see like
them or her getting paid her what she
deserves when like this is what we were
trying to say a year ago was like even
though 500 thousand dollars is a lot of
money it's not
nearly enough for what they bring to the
table yes exactly like and so
wouldn't it have been great if they
could have gotten it together yes but
it's still like an amazing
feat for women and asking for five
hundred thousand dollars now in
hindsight is like
are you [ __ ] kidding me like and and
they were being labeled as greedy for
asking for that when it's like
no no for not for not accepting that
right and like just knowing the market
like knowing how what
you know our podcast brings in and
knowing that podcast is so much bigger
like
no no 20 million is a fair price yeah
and everyone's like it's so much money
that's what the market is
that's the going rate yeah yeah
so interesting congratulations
congratulations are you ready for our
next story
yes tom girardi's alleged victims detail
erica jane's husband's snake behavior
in the housewife and the hustler okay
abc news originals documentary
housewife and the hustler detailed the
allegations against tom gerardi and his
far
firm girardi keis and featured
interviews with his alleged victims
including joe
rugomez who was severely burned and
scarred in 2010 san bruno gas
pipeline explosion by the way the most
interesting part of that documentary was
that story i did not know that that was
[ __ ] crazy ass footage
i know they had so much footage and the
fact that at one point they said that
the firm had 900 cases that they were
doing so like 900 incidents like that
like that's how they made their money
first of all
in all the years that we've known eric
and tom maybe i just wasn't paying
attention or i just didn't understand it
i didn't know that's what tom
did like i understand aaron brockovich
by the way gotta admit i never saw the
movie me neither so like i know i've
heard of it but i do
and i knew it was like a water
contamination but yeah i know the story
put all together that his firm does
cases on behalf of victims who have been
wronged
and that's how they make their partially
wronged by big corporations and that's
how they make their money people like
joe
gomez don't pay tom gerardi he takes on
the case for free because he knows he's
going to win and he gets a piece of the
settlement right which is how it works
also let's just take it back really
quick back strap in case you don't watch
the housewives of beverly hills
erica jane came on the show a few years
ago rich ass
big ass husband lawyer like one of the
biggest lawyers in la his name is tom
girardi
and he's the lawyer from erin brockovich
he got you know that company to pay what
was it like a billion dollars to aaron
and and the crew i don't know i never
saw the movie um
and recently they filed for divorce and
all this thing all these things came out
about tom
and the law firm and if you know tom
he's been on the show a little bit he's
literally a pew job it's the
the last person you would expect so you
thought he was a p drum
now there's a documentary on abc it's on
hulu too it's called the housewife and
the hustler detailing what tom did and
what erica knew
know what they think erica knew you can
never really know what someone knows
i did think it was a little early for a
documentary because no it was a perfect
time because
they are trying like i it couldn't have
come in a better time because on this
week's episode
she announced she's divorced what did
she know what didn't she know
and unless you understood the gravity of
what he's being accused of
you wouldn't you can't watch the
episodes i'm so glad that we got this
right now because we've been seeing all
these stories and i think we've even
reported on some of them and like still
i didn't
i understand i understood that like at
lioner he was accused of not
giving them his money but i had no idea
this was a pattern of behavior for him
for over 40 years by the way the carol
california bar association
shame gusting shame shame
shame shame like let him get away we
shouldn't even want to pass
100 here's the other thing so
basically when you and i didn't know
this like if you are suing like a big
company whether it's an airline or
a manufacturer your lawyer receives the
funds
for you they take their legal fees which
they are owed
because you're not paying them because
that's the agreement and then the rest
of the settlement is given to you
and tom would like prey on these
seemingly innocent people
who had never come into that much wealth
before and you know he's this big rich
lawyer he knows what to do with a lot of
money
and he would say i could give you the
settlement but i have a great investment
opportunity six percent interest you
literally cannot lose money you will
make money every year and
i'll send you disbursements every month
so these people are like oh my god of
course i'm coming into twelve million
twelve million dollars why not make it
twenty and tom would
sometimes send payments sometimes not
and then eventually
never then eventually stopped paying all
together
yeah so it's not just the lion air cage
which in watching the documentary i
like was the absolute saddest part they
had all this footage from
um you guys probably remember when this
happened it was a flight from indonesia
the flight went down and he was
representing some of the victims
families orphans and widows
and they had the footage of like the
airlock the passenger like the shoes and
the
backpacks it was just so sad and they
had they spoke to one of the children
his mom died in the crash and he is
one of four children and they were
representing their tom and they're
waiting on their money and it's like
now watching real housewives and like
knowing that that's probably what's
funding erica jane's
head to toe louis vuitton when there's
like a family in indonesia who doesn't
have parents
and like it's so tough one tragedy like
it's so
terrible and seeing it like spelled out
like that
i i was in shock and also and so what i
was just going to say is we i feel like
we understood that lionel piece of it
but just this documentary explains how
so he did this to so many people that he
represented
and who have been through horrible
unspeakable tragedies not only did he do
that
then he was taking money out of the firm
and funneling it into his own pocket and
putting 20 million dollars
from the key the girardi keys firm which
is
the firm is stealing money from victims
then thomas stealing money from the firm
and put 20 million dollars into ej
global
which is erica jane's company which it
puts on her tours and all of her real
housewife functions and i'm sure pays
for her glam like
so did she know that that investment
from tom was literally money that
belonged to widows orphans and burn
victims
i don't know but there's no way to know
that but also just this idea of like i
mean
when you make your money it's up to you
how you want to spend it and how you
want to show it but the idea that like
his wealth even before he committed a
crime his wealth comes from
these victims who have been through
so he gets paid for these tragedies
really and then you see unreal
housewives like the life that they lead
in like
they can lead that life but to put it
out there like that like knowing where
the money comes from it's just there's
something about it that just
felt a little wrong there's definitely
something like borderline unethical
about what some of his colleagues were
saying it's like this is money that
comes from
people who have suffered and then you go
and you flaunt it on tv
in that way it's weird but it's their
choice and if you're doing everything
legally like
i don't have a problem with that no it's
weird i don't have a problem with that
but but it's a little insensitive
yeah well isn't that what they call like
ambulance chasers yeah
so he's just a really successful one but
like he's basically a celino and barnes
well
now they're just barnes yeah no are they
just celina
they're just silly yeah barnes died damn
don't bring celine barnes into it 100
don't disgrace them
because they they are by the book so i
thought the documentary was
really excellent in explaining to what
heather mcdonald was amazing in the
documentary
said this so well she was like when even
when the questions were asked i watched
what happens i like about these lawsuits
erica sort of shut it down i can't talk
about it and it was just a little too
complicated for people to in heather's
words sink their teeth into and i feel
the same way like this was just like
a mess i'm not a lawyer i don't
understand lawyers get sued so like
i'm not gonna busy myself with it but
like no this is
so and they actually set on a reunion a
few years ago because mauricio
like had a thing and kyle's like this is
just what happens when you're successful
like people see you and that is true
like i do believe like whatever level
you're at like you have lawsuits going
around all the time so
when kyle brushed it off i was like yeah
like it's so true like
and i do believe that but also i did
have one problem with the documentary
and i do feel like um
it was so well done in certain aspects
and then including people like danielle
staub and dana 25 000 like
literally ruined it so much first of all
there's obviously they're just so
thirsty for the fame first of all
second of all they're just so obviously
um
[Music]
they're so intentional and bitter yeah
especially dana like
so i just felt like it really
discredited the and i did think for a
second that it actually
was better to have danielle staub than
dana because danielle stabbed worked at
that strip club that was an interesting
tie-in
but still overall they're so bitter is
the perfect word like
i did not appreciate seeing either of
them i think it ruined the the
seriousness and the credibility of the
documentary because they're both like
has been jokes you know i totally agree
and it's not even like they know erica
and danielle being like i was on watch
inside with her once and like she wasn't
nice like that doesn't mean anything
towards what
her and her husband doesn't mean you
know her and dana who was like yeah well
we heard rumors that they were getting
divorced and they were like can you
elaborate on and she's like
no well why are you on the [ __ ]
documentary like you're allowed to share
rumors you didn't bring anything to the
table but the one thing you might have
you don't say no and also like
their their hypothesis that when you go
on the show you feel compelled to spend
more money to show it off because like
the bar is just raised like
dana is being the epitome of like 20 you
spend 25 000 on a pair of sunglasses
like yeah and you didn't even you
weren't even a full-time cast mate you
were a friend
you should be embarrassed and they were
ugly yeah no that's so true but
but they did um kind of explain for
people who might have watched a
documentary who don't understand like
housewives culture
there is now this category of like
teresa jenshaw
um is that it and erica and luanne
luanne yeah yeah yeah um also i saw the
craziest clip of luanne
on um well on tick tock from like season
two
i remember over quarantine when i
watched i totally forgot about this clip
and it actually was like very bone
chilling what do you remember after
she got divorced from the count she
dated jock who's jewish
and during a scene she said that her
ex would die if she knew that luanne was
with someone jewish
and so andy on the reunion was like you
said that your husband alex account
would die
if you were dating someone jewish like
does he not like jews
and luanne's response was like well it's
not that he doesn't like
jews but he just you know
he would um he would like um just be
very shocked
and i was like this is the weirdest
conversation ever and i was just
reminded of that
because i think i saw it on tic-tacs
this morning or last night um
but i digress from the documentary i
just thought that was an interesting
moment
at all you have to watch it jackie it's
literally the cringiest thing you've
ever seen in your life send it to me
yes so back to housewives who have been
in legal trouble and i feel this way
about jen cha
and erica as well like we need to stop
rewarding these people like after we
know what they've done like
i will give erica the season and maybe
she can explain herself in a way that
will
allow us to believe that she didn't know
about this but my takeaway is like erica
is one of the smartest
most club girls that has ever come on
this show and like
you're married to a lying sociopath and
you don't know
yeah see the thing is i feel like all of
these housewife criminal cases are so
case by case because
i really believe in my soul that like
teresa judas had absolutely no idea what
her husband was doing and not to be mean
teresa's really not that smart and like
she's proven that to us
time and time again and so if joe comes
in it's like okay sign this check she's
like okay like
i i fully in my soul believe that i
don't even like theresa so i would love
to say she knew i really don't think she
knew
and she paid the [ __ ] price like and
and
it's very different to steal from the
government than to steal from widows and
orphans i'm not saying it's okay
but it is a victimless crime i'm sorry
it is yeah no i
i agree then with jen shaw i thought
she was so deplorable like preying on
innocent
old people awful couldn't get worse than
that
tom and erica said hold my beer because
what they did
is ten times worse the only difference
is like in the gen shot case like she's
the one picking up the phone making the
calls where erica does have like this
um she could have an alibi by saying
that it was tom but i think also the
fact that she filed for divorce in
november when the cases started to come
out and like be deposed in september and
october
like and she knew that there was [ __ ]
going down and people think that she
filed for divorce to like hide money
like
that to me would indicate that she knew
and that that divorce
after watching the documentary it felt
like the divorce was had nothing to do
with their relationship and everything
to do with time
no trouble yeah and so i feel like the
documentary's main question that they
posed was what did erica know and of
course they
had no answers for us because no one can
ever really know but
the evidence of the 20 million dollars
going into ej global from girardi keys
is very bizarre the divorce raises a lot
of eyebrows
and just uh what was the other part well
maybe it was just those two things
they didn't really tell us what to think
i think they wanted you to
guess it yourself but you said it
perfectly like erica jane is so smart
that's why we love her she's like so
quick
no one can get anything by her she
called lisa vanner pump out sniper from
the side
second she had her number she can read
anyone
so quickly like she is very
just smart yeah so i would have a hard
time believing that she didn't know but
again there's literally no way for us to
know
because erica has not been named in any
lawsuits erica has not been deposed yet
she
she has been named in a lawsuit and she
her depositions have been delayed
but she hasn't been sued herself she's
just like a part of it because she's the
secretary on all of tom's companies
she herself has not been like indicted
or charged with anything
so nobody knows if she's gonna be but
like that 20 million dollars
once all the public records once all the
records become public
they will be able to find out if the 20
million dollars put in
to erica jane's company from gerardi
keys was settlement money and if that's
the case
she is like blood on your hands
figuratively speaking
but i just want to say whatever happens
in the legal space that's fine but
bravo continuing where do we go from
here to employ
these criminals i'm really like it
really really bothers me
we have to draw a line i agree which
pains me because i have been
an erica jane number one fan with the
same birthday like i we've been obsessed
with her
since the moment she called this event a
problem sniper on the side we're like oh
my god this [ __ ] is smart like
and but you're right like i think we do
have to like have some
ethics here yeah when it comes to the
gen shaw's and i don't include theresa
in that maybe that's wrong of me but i
don't even like theresa
but i don't believe theresa is a
criminal bad person like i think teresa
was married to an animal and would do
anything for him and just like
did what he said well the teresa thing
it's like it's case closed it's
you know and i think the fact that she
served her time on the show and i
mean i don't think anyone really like
we've all moved on from that
um but these are totally different
levels of fraud yeah and just immoral
so now it's like an ethics question like
where do we go from here with with these
two particular housewives
because it's so and that's what one of
the girls on the um documentary said she
was like when we hear about these cases
the first thing we think is like our
camera's rolling so it's like
we want to and we indulge and like we we
fuel that kind of like
salacious gossip but at the end of the
day it's like
so unethical to like give these people a
platform no and like bravo cancels
people for
much less right like you know max and
brett both had like really bad old
tweets
fired fired so it's like what do we do
when someone actually commits a crime
and this is actually you know
always hearts back to my book girls in
the job available on amazon
talked about this a lot like cancel
culture people who do bad things versus
people who say bad things
i feel like in this day and age we like
punish people who say bad things worse
than we punish people who do bad things
yeah no and these are just like
completely
too extreme right like what you're a
criminal yeah
i mean but i am going to watch the rest
of the season like
really trying to understand erica's
position
like i'm going to try and keep an open
mind i think the documentary was really
damning
yes but there's two sides to every story
you don't know what erica you don't know
what tom brought home but i just want to
say that was my
gut instinct was she's a smart girl yeah
20 years
she doesn't know and by the way the
documentary ended basically saying that
they're still doing all these
depositions and stuff obviously it's
been delayed because of cobid
but tom is 81 and now they have a
psychiatrist saying he
has alzheimer's so we might not even be
able to stand trial but they also have
his friends saying we've seen time
we saw him right before kobed like at
events okay he was speaking very clearly
yeah so that's that on that i'm ready to
move on but
looking forward to the developing news
are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by coors pure
coors pure do you ever feel like living
a healthy lifestyle is hard like you try
super hard to keep up with what is
considered healthy
you push yourself each day getting
better and better but it can be
overwhelming
that's why we want to introduce you to
coors pure it's an organic
but chill about it new course pure is a
refreshingly simple beer with organic
barley organic hops and water
at just 92 calories and zero sugar it is
the perfect beer to celebrate the wins
of everyday life
course pure is all about promoting
balance and giving aggressive
affirmations to everyday heroes
whether you got your run in or you just
got as far as putting on your running
shoes
coors pure is celebrating you it's
organic but chill about
it so i feel like course prayer is kind
of like a brand we've been eating for a
while when you do
just want to kind of take some time have
a beer but it has to be you know
you don't want to set yourself back if
you're doing so well coarse pure is 92
calories completely organic and it has
zero
sugar it is a perfect beer to celebrate
the winds of everyday life so when you
want to enjoy a beer without the guilt
reach for the cure the core is pure it
is organic but chill about it
and go to coorspure.com to see where you
can find course pure and that's spelled
c-o-o-r-s-p-u-r-e dot com
celebrate responsibly course brewing
company albany georgia
again check it out coursepjor.com for
the wins of everyday life when you just
want to like have a beer and not like
make a big deal about it you know
no totally and a good time to have a
course pure is when you're celebrating
your one year anniversary just like
kendall jenner and devin booker
were this weekend okay this was really
surprising to me kendall jenner and
phoenix suns guard devin booker marked a
major relationship milestone over the
weekend their one year anniversary
taking to instagram on saturday the
couple posted tributes to one another
including a cozy snap of kendall
wrapping her arms around devin on the
plane and
you know they had a sunset photo where
he captioned one
they're tagging each other this is like
the most we've ever gotten
from them and i was really surprised one
i didn't know that it was been a year of
like them being linked
yeah i also don't think those were
recent photos because he's playing in
the nba playoffs and she was in mexico
this weekend with haley baldwin
they had like a sickening girls weekend
drinking it when 818 it looked so
[ __ ] funny they did look really fun i
like went to all the people they tagged
just to like see more
literally they looked so fun i was like
why am i not there oh i believe these
are just like you know when you post
like a photo dump
they took a photo dump yeah okay good to
know i'm sad they couldn't celebrate
together but i'm happy for kendall that
she's like in
a long-ass relationship i know i kind of
feel like
you know i've been i feel like he could
be the one
i actually don't really keep a lot of
tabs on kendall jenner's relationships
because she usually dates people i don't
know like i don't know devin booker but
like now i do
ben simmons i don't know but like now i
do and i just feel like she dates the
same person like just
in different cities so i just never
really like and she always states people
who she's more famous than so like
i really there's not that many people
that are more famous that's also true
so i don't really keep up but this one
now it's like there's proof in the
pudding
i'm alert i'm alerted to this and also
i've been watching so much basketball
with ben that like i'm fully
you know keeping up with the booker's
fleeting
sons point guard super cute like very
good player so i'm like now learning
more information
um and i think it's super cute these
pictures were very cute and always i
think there's
real credibility in a relationship based
on like how you know private it is and
this is very private yeah no
this all signs were looking good i was
really surprised to see it i didn't
really even realize she was in a
relationship well i remember that at the
beginning of the pandemic they took like
a
car a road trip and a convertible from
la to phoenix because that's where he
plays and people were like
you were in a convertible without mass
like that was the worst time of the
[ __ ] year like
kendall jenner got in trouble for being
in a convertible without a mask it's
like oh my shut the [ __ ] up like
now knowing what we know like that makes
no [ __ ] sense she's outside
and the wind is blowing like it's so
stupid and she's in a car with just her
boyfriend like so stupid
um but so now i know like that was over
a year ago and so i guess they called
they
made it official this time last year
yeah oh very very cute
all makes sense the pictures from the
from the convertible
road trip were so cute and the pictures
from this dump are really cute like i
love
it it just shows that they've had like a
really cute cozy year like obviously
them being cuddling on the pj is
like extra so cute yes wouldn't be as
cute if it was commercial
no no no no oh no i also feel like
girls or just people who have date
basketball players or professional
athletes have had like the best time
this year because
so many games are canceled and if they
weren't canceled they were in a bubble
so they didn't have to travel they were
just like all in orlando
yeah so just feel like it was a great
time to be a wag yeah i would agree with
that and maybe
the only time we really ever needed wags
back on the air was this year
oh i miss wags bringing back wags you
never watch
i watched like a couple yeah you didn't
because you would have been hooked no no
i did i definitely saw like the first
episode
clearly didn't watch i loved the premise
watching girlfriends
no it was so good like bring back wax
okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story just like such good exciting news
to end on
it's the final story
sure now i'm ready beauty and the beast
prequel has been ordered to disney plus
this is literally what we've been saying
for a year
gaston prequel wait we literally came up
with this idea and it's a series
a live-action musical series gaston the
prequel will star luke evans as
and josh gad they'll reprise the role of
gaston and lefou
the food's name is louie
and there will be a newcomer brianna
middleton who will join the show is
tilly
who is lethu's stepsister the prequel
series was first announced as being in
development in march
2020 but i'm sure with all the other
news like this nobody copies
or we reported on it but it's just been
such a long year that we forgot wait i'm
like quaking one that this is happening
and two that we're getting the band back
together because honestly
no one will ever be gaston better than
luke evans i'm obsessed with him
josh gad is an amazing lifu
amazing and this is just the feel good
story the good
news that i needed today no 100 i
actually was just watching beauty and
the beast on friday
and i was watching gaston and i was
remarking how like luke evans is so good
and and
so is josh gagnon i was actually
thinking hugh jackman i think played
um gaston on broadway
london's broadway west way west end
and that's why it works and he also like
is the only other person who i think
would be like such an amazing gaston but
these two
luke and josh are just the dream team
i also feel like you know not to be
aegis but i do think like you know yeah
no i hear you jackman has aged out of
the role of you
say it he could be gaston's dad in the
prequel he or he could play gaston in
the sequel
yeah yeah like after beauty in the case
yeah yeah hundreds
what happens to gaston and there's the
french revolution i'm sure he was a big
hero so we're gonna see he comes back to
the little town it's a quiet village
with like all this respect for being a
war hero correct but it wasn't
based on the timeline it was like not
the it was pre-french revolution wars so
it's just like a
hypothetical war he's like no no i'm
sure they were real like
it's rooted in history it's definitely
weird in history disney does not mess
around they don't [ __ ] around
so i'm just really excited a little
prequel news i wonder what they'll call
it
me too maybe they'll call it gaston
that was not our best we haven't done it
in so long
it feels good it feels good anyway i
hope they reprise that song in one way
or another like maybe it's a theme song
i'm sure that song actually gives the
whole story of gaston like when he was a
boy he ate five dozen eggs so we'll see
like
an episode of the series five doesn't
exist help him get his punches
from the back oh that's not cool that's
not cool
that's true that's that maybe that song
was the inspiration
for the quote he tells him everything
you need to know about gaston really
so and now he's the size of a barge
anyways
he is the size of a barge um all right
we're gonna get into a little content
recap
from the weekend brought to you by hair
food hair food offers simple superfood
inspired products that will make your
hair look and feel amazing whatever hair
texture or hair type you have
hair food has a recipe for you in
addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes the apple cider vinegar hair
rinse which is perfect for days where
your hair needs a gentle cleanse
they have a tumeric and almond oil
detangling milk which takes care of the
most stubborn knots and reduces frizz
and the shea butter and pear color
repair concentrate which makes
over-processed hair look vibrant and
healthy
all the products smell so good they're
made so well they're free
all the products are free of sulfates
parabens dyes minerals oils and they're
certified
pita cruelty free so if you want to
check out uh hair food and get nourished
healthy hair one of my favorite products
is the detangling milk made with
turmeric and almond oil
um i just like forgot that adults can
and should be using
detangling detanglers um
and that one's a really good one it
smells really good and it's made with
really good products so if you're
looking for nourished healthy hair it's
got to be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
love hair food
so last night the bachelorette was on i
did not watch because i'm sticking
you know that's my resolution i'm
committing to things how could you even
mention that
what that it was on what are you gonna
say
to check out the snatcher oh okay what
else was i
i don't know i thought you like watch
and i was like oh wow i actually told
even though i was watching um
theo and bruno and magnolia for margot
while she watched and recorded the
snatcher
i like actually forgot the bachelorette
was on i was like no what's crazy
is that like there's no commotion
there's no tweets there's no stories
like
i didn't even know but i guess they
showed a preview blake from last season
you actually liked him remember
for a minute boylan and then we hey like
moines okay blake moorland he comes
on kd season i guess he's like obsessed
so that's like the the anchor
like that people are like blake here's
everything you need e news
five things you need to know about blake
who [ __ ] cares did you get that
article a year ago
did you did blake already come no so
they showed it in the preview so like
that's the only sort of like news i'm
seeing so i'm like really worried
when do we get the ratings how uh do you
get them the next morning
i think maybe two days out because
that's what you shared okay
i'm going to find it and i want to share
it tomorrow because there's no news
no commotion no puzzle except for the
snatcher that's actually the only reason
i know it's not because she posts like
the best memes
it's at it's the snatcher um if you're
looking for a recap
it will be up in like an hour she came
over last night after to pick up knolls
by the way bruno knowles they were
playing so hard last night it was
actually so cute
and she said the episode is so great so
be sure to check it out
the worse the bachelor is the better the
snatcher is
like it's just so easy to make fun of
these like chaotic morons but like when
it's actually a cute love story like
what are you gonna say it's so cute like
yes podcast isn't very long
yeah no i totally agree so i did not
watch um
but if you did and you're looking for
some sort of recap the snatcher always
has you covered i feel so good having
the bachelor
out of my life i know even though i'm
coming back for about term paradise but
then i'm out
we've got so much content this week
tonight by the way we are going to a
fabulous party
we are i'm so excited i'm gonna wear
that hat to the party tonight
oh i should definitely wear a hat to the
party we're going to a pride party i'm
so excited so that's
we'll be recapping that tomorrow also
this week is the keeping up with the
kardashians part 1 reunion
and some of the clips have been emerging
i know and looks so good i'm
so excited we also have real housewives
of beverly hills now first episode
talking about the divorce and the
lawsuits garcelle asking the hard
questions
thank you garcelle and i just want to
reiterate i'm just so glad that i've now
watched this and now i can go in like
with
the full picture yeah it's called the
hustler the housewife and it's on hulu
so if you want to watch that
before wednesday i recommend it and then
my third critique of the
of the documentary is just that title i
agree it makes it so
like not serious
even though it was a really well done
documentary and it covers really serious
issues
and they opened it with danielle's stab
and her shoes and i was like this is a
joke
but then it turned out not to be a joke
so i just feel like they couldn't decide
if they wanted to make it serious or not
yeah no
danielle's having her shoes and it's
like oh wait does danielle stop like
know something and have the tea
right he's like no she doesn't i thought
heather mcdonald was a great person to
have on it i thought sunny hosting even
though i do find her a little annoying
i did think she was a great person to
like dumb down a lot of the legal stuff
for me and i appreciated that
i thought a lot of the reporters were
very smart i just and i i think they
needed someone from the housewives like
the two people they chose like was just
a no for me yeah i totally agree
but it's still a good documentary yeah
that's our show
that's our show and we'll be back
tomorrow i'm really excited
for you know our little project this
afternoon but also to watch why women
kill thoroughly enjoying it if you're
looking for like a good pick you up show
for me it reminds me so much of
obviously desperate housewives like the
music and everything but also
she devil the movie with meryl streep
and roseanne
we watched it on toast movie of the week
last year during um
the pandemic when we were all watching
movies oh my god we did that movie is so
chaotic
it's it's a chaotic iconic and reminds
me of why women kill i don't think
anyone would dislike it i'm really
enjoying the show
also it's like a little like um campy
you know that yes
but that's just that's the mark cherry
effect i don't know something about
desperate housewives is more soapy like
well you know what
this isn't like a soap opera you know
who makes it very campy with her bad
acting is jennifer goodwin
i think there's a lot of bad acting lucy
lou too but she gets no no she's a
really good actress it's like she's just
in these
um like crazy stories but i think like
the
modern day some of the modern day actors
are not it it gets better um
also the show also reminds me of mad men
just the jennifer goodwin parts
yeah i love the premise of the house and
me too i think it's really
really good so need that house also is
that the house from the
politician when he's growing up in san
diego no way no that house is the santa
barbara house is like
palatial okay it looks very similar oh i
didn't get the vibe okay
um well that's our show and we so
appreciate you guys hanging with us and
just being cool you know
yeah thanks for being cool thanks so
much for listening to the morning chose
the monday morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and our podcast
be podcasting me foundation spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cat's box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
guys have an amazing day and we'll see
you tomorrow for what day is it
hump day bye